well I want to ask you two questions
about filmmaking and acting but just
first have to interject with the
question of being called the new Ingmar
Bergman how does that make you feel what
type of responsibility it's very
interesting you know because the Swedish
film industry is divided in two parts
basically and one was in my Bergman part
and other one was do bill debate and I
have always been connected with the
boovie develop art because the producer
that I started working with Kelly woman
he worked with booby deliver in the 60s
so I have never been there Ingmar
Bergman when it comes to Swedish film
industry at least so here then it's kind
of nice so you have heard it but I'm
wondering with the sense of
responsibility that's around that too
because that would put a lot of pressure
on someone no I don't have any problem
with pressure actually I try to enjoy
the pressure I'm I I don't take it that
seriously I must say but but you know
sometimes it's good to have high goals
or what you say high expectations if you
say for example I you I love to say okay
next film will be in competition in
camera because then you have to perform
better and you have to push everybody in
the production in order to perform
better if you don't know where you are
aiming for then it would be a very hard
to increase your performance so I think
it's important to have high expectations
on yourself and not take them too
seriously but at the same time let those
high expectations
encourage you and it goes back to
uncomfortability as well with yes
fascinating
screaming but maybe not so great in real
life mmm okay so for writing the square
how many pages what's the script I don't
remember I was at 124 something like
that
I think yeah yeah yes and I write in a
more literary way first so and then I
have someone doing an American standard
script out of that the first script I'm
writing but I like much more to write in
a literal way where you can write where
what the characters are thinking and
things like that things that is quite
hard to show when it comes to a visual
product but so I ran into kind of
different way and both of the scripts
that I've been doing actually I'm a
published snowbunny's also the force
majeure and the square so Terry when
you're presented with a script what is
your process for going through it and
saying as for project well I said yes to
a project after we had a FaceTime
conversation and he laughed and I
laughed and we just said we had I liked
him when I met him I'm on FaceTime and I
thought his ideas were great and I saw
force majeure and I loved that film and
I thought he's gonna make me look good
so I I just loved his sensibility and
the way he shoots he takes time you know
those moments to play out in time
nothing feels rushed and
I feel like the weight capture scenes is
was the setups the shots the angles he
takes all had a really interesting way
of telling a story so it would be an
exciting adventure to join and and I'm
very happy that I did absolutely um I
knew you're a professor at University
yes okay um can we talk about if there
was a theoretical square in the
classroom so let's say the classroom is
a safe place to talk about ideas and
critique work even with actors do you
think that it's more of a it's a less
critical space the classroom rather than
if you see a trailer a film screen you
see the trades one is more likely to
criticize another's work for whatever
reasons they have but the the classroom
setting itself is its own square well
what I think is important when it comes
to the classroom is that you should not
look to how to say personally on your
work you should separate yourself from
you from your work
because in that in that way you can be
able to take criticism when it comes to
your work without making it a personal
problem we're actually talking about
something that is outside of yourself
now so and of course that is hard in the
beginning when you're new in doing
movies and things like that because
everybody wants to make it everybody
wants to be the one that is being able
to be professional and work with this
and business in this industry and the
competition is hard so it's very easy to
take it personally so it's a it's a
dilemma really you know because I was
when you when it comes to the University
and there's only six students in every
grade on the University where I what I
teach
so there's few students and they are
comparing each other we wheel each other
but you know the best thing if you
manage to create it is of course people
encourage them to have ambition not
being afraid of failing and push
themself they have to push themselves
also it's great if you like you can't
create the kind of dynamics in the
classroom that is like come on now we
are we are will we're onto something
that's interesting let's perform the
best we can perform and put in some
energy in your work and take your work
seriously at the same time take risks
and if you fail no worries you just
tried next time again mmm that's one
thing that that room is really good at
is allowing that space to happen and
that's what I experienced on this film
working with him was not being afraid to
make mistakes and I think that was one
of the keys to the the the way we work
together I felt like I could just lose
myself and not worry about hitting marks
and and making it perfect because the
the gems are really in the mistakes
they're hidden within the mistakes
because there's there the moments that
flush out and become things and and and
so that was yeah yeah I think that's a
very important thing to not be afraid to
get in and lose yourself work hard
go far as you can go and then take it
even that much further he pushes you
even that much further so you're just
like you have to lose yourself and then
you forget yourself and then you can
actually be in the moment and and and
really just a reactor rather than trying
to do accomplish something weird and
that's the whole primary metaphor is
that we all have those tendencies of the
primate but we're self-conscious whereas
the primate is at peace tippy I think
the monkey and that's self-consciousness
it comes from fear comes from the fear
of not doing something when I not being
liked or not being not not you know
appealing to everyone or being you know
friends or doing it right you know doing
it right so when you lose that you just
things start happening that you couldn't
imagine that you can try to try to do
they just they just appear in front of
you and you just embrace them and run
with it no but I think it's one one
thing that I also as a director you are
scared to not live up to the role that
it is expected from you and I think that
every day when I come to set I are in
like you know almost panic oh my god
this is being so bad and I did that I
have here on a script I thought it would
be so good but as soon as you set up the
camera you start shooting again if you
like
how should I solve this you know and in
the beginning we are on a career then
you are afraid to expose that but when
the more that you have worked and you
actually can be transparent and you can
say I don't know yet but give me an
example let's try and you try out to say
no it's not in that way and when you are
transparent with it then you can like
find a solution on how to deal with the
scene and not be too obsessed with
yourself playing a role of being a
director because in secureness is
something that is very important if you
are a director because that's connected
to you instrument so when you see it's
not right you know that's right and it's
still not right but they
it is the only thing that we should be
able to do as a director is being true
to instruments so in the moment when you
find it there it is then then then your
then your profession is like how to say
that's what you're aiming for to get
that moment and if you don't stay true
to your instrument and you just want to
pretend that you are in control you know
then then you're losing the reason why
you should be a director so exposed when
you don't know what you do and lucky and
still you have to be in control of it
you're the Wonder is running the show
you know so it can't be like there are
10 shifts it'd have to be one chef but
then give time to yourself and trying to
figure out what is it that I don't want
what is it that I want and when you find
it yeah okay here it is but yeah so time
on set is important to me mmm the same
same for an actor same exact process you
can't come in as an actor and go well
I'm an actor and this I know I'm gonna
die I know exactly what I'm gonna do and
I says I'm gonna nail it you know the
first take you know you got a you got a
note allow yourself to do it wrong and
go no that's not it and just try
something different okay though yes
okay we're onto something here okay and
my glute home and then all of a sudden
you just like pull and you just it
starts like it's like a it's like a
symphony and all of sudden the symphony
comes together and you're like wow it
comes up and you're like it's happening
and you just go boom allowed to continue
to happen this is working we're in it
we're in it we're in it let's just allow
to continue
go go and then just the moments come and
then moments start appearing in front of
you and then you just embrace them and
you've embraced the fear what you call
it we call it as actors you take the
fear and you go I'm not gonna go oh I'm
not supposed to be afraid I'm an actor
and you know you embrace the fear you
got I'm afraid I'm scared shitless right
now and I'm gonna take it and I'm gonna
use it as fuel yeah do you think
overconfidence is the mark of an amateur
no I think it can be good sometimes you
know that you're like
we're going to create something that is
historical we're going to make a season
that is like really really good that is
a good ambition for me but but but you
also have to allow yourself to struggle
with decision and be able to you know
dare to stay in that struggle and and I
think that's something that is important
when it comes to like shooting for an
example I think time onset is something
that is so important for me because
otherwise I I could only cover up the
script you know only shooting the script
so we can maybe put this together in the
editing room but for me it's like okay
how do we create something unique to
happen on set in front of the cameras
and then you need time so I think I
think that the young directors that are
looking at this double the amount of
shooting days and then ask the producer
to count on how we make this possible
because very often it's about the
structure how we use the money on on
shooting the the films that I have made
have been costing maybe 5 million euros
what's the square and I said to the
producer
I want 70 shooting days and then he has
to calculate how to use the money so it
makes it possible so we actually have to
be able to think out of the box and
think out of the normal way of producing
a movie in order to get the
circumstances that we need to perform in
a good way on the level that we want to
perform so think outside of the box how
do you create time on set if that it was
you need
yeah and speaking of time
two-and-a-half-hour movie I actually
would have enjoyed a five hour movie
because I was I was lost in the world of
Christian but how did you and I don't
want to use the word defend but how did
you keep that time with your
distributors mmm when often we wanted to
go to the pump it was no from the middle
who's it correct for that no you know I
can I can understand that they have a
time slot in the cinemas that they have
to deal with and if you have a film that
is over two hours then you can't screen
the film as many times on one night so
that is of course a practical problem
but for me if I look at the the the
greatest experience I've had of cinema
the last ten years
all of the movies that that was like
that have been over three hours almost
it was blue is the warmest color
Lawrence anyways holy Motors and all of
them were like if giving me a ride that
is longer than two hours so I could I
have to trust that also you know that
that and if we're going to push this
show with this perform is a little bit
longer for the audience they will also
have a stronger impression afterwards
you